hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge hexe auf dem heroes
server wo ich diesmal eure kommentare
beantworten die mir unter die letzten
folgen so geschrieben habt und zwar geht
es da über ganz verschiedene sachen geht
über sachen die ich mir bauen soll hier
habe ich übrigens ich habe das schon
einen kleinen feier trennen und zwar ach
nee das war ein auto bei uns hier dass
sie sowas abgegangen also ich werde
erstmal mein haus hier dabei ein
bisschen weiter vorne habe ich mir
gedacht es gibt doch nichts schöneres
als wenn man sich ein haus baut ihr
nehmt euch jetzt den schönen t ich meine
so scheiß wetter ich hab klausur
geschrieben ich war von morgens 7 uhr
morgens 7 550 bis übermorgen 57 bis
jetzt 16 30 in der schule ich bin quasi
im dunkeln hingefahren und im dunkel
zurückgefahren oder mit dem auto im stau
und alles und blabla das ist alles sehr
heftig deftig scheiße gewesen und es ist
einfach so ein blödes wetter draußen ist
es einfach so ein wetter du kommst im
dunkeln in der schule und fährst im
dunkeln wieder das ist so kacke weil du
dann irgendwie weiß nicht mal ist total
schlecht drauf irgendwie ich weiß nicht
ich bin dann immer ein bisschen
depressiv aber ich dachte jetzt mal ein
bisschen aufgelegt die das anders und
wir brauchen wartet aus welchem holz
wollte ich dann die stimme hier bauen
wollte das aus dem heftigen holzmachen
oder aus dem hier aus dem hier oder aus
dem ich weiß nicht worauf sieht das
besser aus ihr könnt mir das ja auch mal
eigentlich immer schreiben in die
kommentare ob ihr weil es hier soll ein
haus werden von mir und von recht
aufregen könnt ihr das ja auch damit
bestimmen ist dem erscheinen das ist
total doof mann hast du dich richtig
klein welcher soll zwar falsch ich drück
soll es klein werden übrigens müssen
hier die pfeiler glaube ich hin
jedoch nicht dass es wollte ich außen
rum bauen oder möchte das außen rum
bauen jedoch hier könnte ich theoretisch
die pfeiler hin packe ich mache das hier
alles und jetzt das doch wieder so wie
ich das doch so hinstelle er ist es auch
so kann das irgendwie nur schütz zu
verstehen nochmal ich dachte sich können
diese eine seite hier nehmen von den rap
redwood lockt das mit auch ganz okay aus
lehm mit auto und mache ich das gar
nicht dann nehme ich lieber die sehr
heftigen teile und in den händen von
zombie noch ein paar das nach pflanzt
kann ich das machen
also ich werde eure kommentare so ein
bisschen beantworten in dieser folge da
sitzen einfach 2 diabetes und will ihn
da hingestellt unfall oder keine ahnung
ich werde einfach eure kommentare
beantworten so ein bisschen und zwar die
mutter die letzten folgen selber
geschrieben wurden
da stand ja mal ein paar sachen von
tipps über dieses schild ist ein mega
gewartet als ich wette euren namen
vorlesen vielleicht soll ich sowas
nochmal machen dann könnte ihm jetzt
immer ganz viele kommentare schreiben
bekommt die eventuell bald dran
ich bin ein bisschen erkältet und habe
halt schmerz und alles ich hoffe dass es
stört euch deutlich weiter ich wollte
jetzt einfach nur was auch nie weil ich
werde immer auf meiner facebook-seite
gefragt kommt hero dann antworte ich
meiner schule ab nachfolger schlimm
kommt nichts aufnehmer jedenfalls fix
famous lp hat geschrieben das ist gut
dieses schild also die meisten möglich
dass dieses schild mega gut ist weil es
im gegensatz zu meinem kopf guck mal
rechts weil die hunger balken
da braut sich etwas auf und das geht
dann zurück und das beugt sich irgendwie
ganz ganz langsam wieder neu auf wenn
ich dieses komische schild in der hand
halte was ich übrigens auch gar nicht in
der hand halte erstmal wenig ändere die
heile rechts ich mache kriege ich einen
emmerich das mit 81 ps macht krieg in
everett damit kann ich traden also ich
hab mir schon also müssen durchgelesen
schöner heber eventuell paco rabanne
shader rein ich weiß nicht ich hab ich
bock drauf
ja ich mache die teile hierhin hier ich
mach das mal vier hoch
und ich werde auch wahrscheinlich
sondern cool bogen holen der so richtig
den werde ich dann lesen holen die man
irgendwie firma auf einmal werfen kann
die bietet vorgestellt das ist wurde
ganz gute waffe dann einfach so benutzen
kannst einfach umlaufen tiere töten so
68 miteinander dem brand brain und an
basta 4
sowas hätte ich mich wahrscheinlich noch
machen und das schild es wohl so gut
weil sich das irgendwie wieder neu
aufbaut
keine ahnung was genau das jetzt
bedeutet aber dass baut sich ich habe
eine nachricht bekam dass pohl
dementsprechende auf dass das wohl total
schnell wieder neue lädt und irgendwie
auch während dessen neue lebt und keine
ahnung ich verändere ich ende jetzt
einfach mal das haus hier damit dass
jetzt nicht ganz so beruf aussieht wenn
ich das jetzt irgendwie sind auseinander
flüge also kommission kommt dahin und
zwar will ich hier eigentlich dann wenn
ein häuslein hinbauen dabei auch mal ein
handy halten schwarz selbst das heißt es
wird einfach es wird halt einfach dann
hier reingehen vier so weit habe ich
nicht nachgedacht
hier kommt dann erst mal hier mache ich
dann glaube ich so eine wand hin
also das ist ja das oder soll ich das
auch noch mit zu meinem haus dann
zufügen
egal kommerziell noch überlegen ich
mache das jetzt erst mal zu in mainz
läuft uns ja nicht weg sondern kann ich
das ja auch eben durch das ersetzen mit
dass hier ein bisschen schöner aus den
sieht man zwar ähnlich aber naja hier
den eingang den den könnten die noch
schöner bauen
ich glaube ich mache mir auch so einen
coolen eingang oder was habe ich hier
flagge
ich habe hier so ein er möchte aber auch
diese komische stückchen da haben
naja egal dann steht das neue rad vom
kongress daneben kämpfen inzwischen zeit
ruhig hier jetzt wieder ach so konnten
im die mol chart bleiben das ist mister
darth vader mlpd mir das geschrieben
übrigens dass die folge zu spät kommt
wie gesagt so geschrieben alles mögliche
und wiegen sich sonnen kisten
transporter machen das haben wir auch
richtig richtig hineingeschrieben
transporter damit ich die kiste an ihm
gehören kann das nur als nächstes soll
wohl auch mega einfach seine server
einfach wie ihr gerade gesehen habt
deswegen macht das mal so ich glaube ich
brauche dafür acht steaks so dann gehe
ich hier in dem crafting table von
unserm netten nachbarn dann mache ich
mir hier ein jazz transporter und jetzt
probieren wir das mal dass es irgendwie
doof dass ich in dieser zeit
guck mal wie geil die kirche ist weg was
da alles drin auch da sind einfach nur
so einfach nur öffentliche bratsche
da kommt das da rein oder via kanada die
auch drauf kommen können
ich will unsere stadt ist von allen
städten um organisiertes nicht so schön
geworden unserer stadt ach das ist schon
okay dachstuhl vestas also ich hab ja
nachtsicht ich kann immer ganz eben
schon mal bei den blick nehmen so jetzt
habe ich eine kiste ist habe ich diese
verlangsamung alles möglich aber ich
kann all die kiste an sich mitnehmen das
zahl relativ gut wenn ich erst wenn ich
glaube ich noch langsamer ich kann noch
gar nicht erst danke an euch die mir das
geschrieben haben das ist auf jeden fall
mega gut mit dem jazz transport ich
werde nie im leben darauf gekommen
ich habe ihn angeguckt mein gott jetzt
habe ich auch einen schlag verlangsame
oder wie oh mein gott kacke aber das
ganz gut weil das die rheinländer mit
ist weil ich kann mir dann endlich
vielleicht mal bald sollen allerdings
machen dass ich mich nach hause zu
importieren können
ich weiß nicht was schneller geht geht
schneller wenn ich die abbauen
das ganze holz zum mitnehmen das brauche
ich ja irgendwie jetzt einfach so
mitnehmen
ich kann ich auch einfach so mitnehmen
da ist nix drin
ich krieg wahrscheinlich war das
inventar blockieren dich weil du kannst
dann auch hier rein dann packe ich hier
noch gegen eine gold für der woche und
zwar weil ich diese ganzen emerald
kaffee tee mitnehmen
auch hier habe ich davon gar nicht
möglich doppels tech 3 traurig traurig
nicht viel an
so läuft das jungs so jetzt habe ich
mich hiervon ab 8 und jetzt habe ich ein
emerald letztendlich ganz schön dich mit
dem emerald kann ich es mit den leuten
da handeln die in der stadt da wurden so
schätzt transporthubschrauber start weg
gelegt
ob ich dumm bin habe ich gefragt braucht
junge macht dich so behindert korrekt
habe ich den
da sehe ich den einfach nur gerade oder
ist er irgendwie selber sehe ich den
gerade oder warst als ratlos und habe
ich den hier eben vor ausgeschlossen
müller ist ja auch nicht drin dies ist
schwimmen schilt schild will bolt soll
sogar sein dass freue ich mich richtig
auf das benutzen darf
kann ich jetzt mal ganz kurz schlafen
damit ich in front einsetzen kann
so macht ihr ein legia bogen wurde mir
auch sehr oft geschrieben elia bogen von
andi schweiger die abo natürlich direkt
dann muss ich eben denkt man ja jungs
ich höre jetzt echt mega gern mein
kisten transporter wieder habe er vom 09
wir haben sie alle wieder machen wir
gleich mehrere 24
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt gebracht hat
oder ob ich denn wirklich irgendwo
verloren habe aber naja
übrigens viele leute meint noch unter
anderem elemente endemann an der matif
summer aber dass ich mir allerdings
machen soll
eine fifa eine pink poms armor ein
komplettset drin
ich befinde
scale richtung ja ich habe verstanden
andere von denen ja ich werde mir das
game machen wenn ich denn genug hexie
kalex tänzen hab da wäre ich mir von
seiner rüstung ständer machen dann werde
ich auf den einen dann die dings
draufpacken die die welcher euch denen
die triebe haben oder welche gar nicht
mehr contents 388 alle fluglotsen vor
der küste so dass die an auf jeden fall
besser liegen direkt kaputt dabei dass
die besser sein soll weil die gesetzlich
besser ist geschmackssache die hat er
zwar nicht die nachtsicht aber dass ich
denke wenn ich bei nacht irgendwo rum
laufe dann nehme ich eben schoko mit
meinem keyboard nachtsicht weil das das
schwarze ist
wir haben noch keinen golden ist glaube
ich gerade gehe bin ich das hatte ich
dann habe ich da in 80 und ja dann ist
es relativ egal und die hat halt mehr
stärke und ich glaub feuer resistenz hat
dieses gerüst und dann denke ich mal die
scale rüstung machen sondern auch auf
jeden fall cooler sein wird muss ich
gleich noch die schweinchen hier
mitnehmen und schoki halt nur noch das
fast so schweinchen ich da hinten
nämlich auch mit
mit mir durch so komfortabel kommen
jetzt mit
ich muss euch wieder die tür kaputt
schlagen
da kommen die essensausgabe hinter werth
hat werde ich wahrscheinlich immer mal
live spiel machen wenn ich dann nicht
sterben wenn die qualität
dementsprechend gut ist dann werde ich
hier eine essens vergabe ausmachen also
was damit sie nicht 20.000 voll mit
füllen gilt das lieber zwei stunden live
stream oder cisco ihr könnt diesen
wieder zu dorf dadurch mehr kann ich
jetzt hier ein weg schieben die krise
mit euch
komm schmidt kommt ja noch lang da 68
da musst du doch noch für die buddel wo
die reihe können ich frag mich auch
immer noch ok das war wirklich da drin
als ob er nur zwei kisten da hat und
dann noch nicht so richtig gebaut hat
uns auf jeden fall cool dass ich jetzt
so hiermit stadt wohne oder was halt
jeder oder würdet ihr sagen ob anna da
wieder rein
ihr sollt hier rein dem blöden oder ich
mach da ebenso provisorisch ich wusste
dass ihr zu blöd seit ich wusste es
einfach mal
die krise hier mit euch doch jetzt hat
kommt solche blöden schweige ich dachte
anfangs dieser schweine werden cool aber
jetzt weiß ich warum wir nur am ende bei
mcdonald's landeten nicht in
irgendwelchen unternehmen in den
führungsetagen ihr könnt nur
geschlachtet werden ihr seid einfach
blöd vor allem druck weg was wird craig
es wohl machen bin ich jetzt einfach mal
zehn sekunden gucke dreht sich hoch und
er guckt er beschnuppert blumen oder
kauft wieder zurück korrekt ist so blöd
jetzt läuft am weg zu den blüten und
wieder zurück wieder zu den blüten auch
der ist so doof der typ- oder die typen
kanal unter jungen mädel ist ja so gut
das haus geht quasi noch mal ein weiter
hier rein
ich habe auch gedacht dass ich mir so
zwischen pfeiler hier das gebäude rein
mache auch aus diesem spiel
dann kommt die tür erst mal vernünftig
für musste da komme ich ja sogar
befinden aber da muss ich ja theoretisch
mal so machen hier macht das einfach
hier aus denkt dran so dann packe ich
einfach nochmal diese pfeile oder da ist
eigentlich besser oder mathe wie haben
die das da vorne gelöst das wollte aber
vor hingucken das so gemacht
ich weiß nicht ich finde es ihm die
kulig finden drei abstand immer viel
viel geiler als in zwei abstand macht
das jetzt mal so einfach hier auch ich
weiß nicht wie das besser aussieht
so
ich weiß nicht dann kann man ja
eventuell noch so machen ja keine ahnung
muss einfach gucken so was ich machen
wollte ist ich muss eigentlich mich
erstmal das äußere kümmern ich wollte
hier in noch so ein paar bäume ich eine
rein machen und zwar wenn man so
reingeht vielleicht sogar zwei jahren
platz hätte ich ja ich könnte ja das
ganze einfach mal obwohl wird es dann
noch passen ja kommt das schaffe ich
glaub ich sogar noch in dieser folge es
ist blöd weil hier mit karts alles auf
den kopf stelle mehr oder weniger was
ich vorhin so gemacht habe das heißt
alles war so ein bisschen halt du hier
muss auch noch weg aber müsste der zonen
nicht auch noch abfall wegen dem motto
dezember dezember ist eine liter von
pitbull kesha heißt es auch immer jetzt
übrigens diese folgerichtig leise weil
ich halt wie gesagt ich habe mein herz
ist kaputt aber ihr meint alle ray mach
mal ein video von cia und ich wollte
mich eigentlich in ruhe liegen und am
ende halt einfach ein video dachte ich
mir okay wenn er das meint da macht das
natürlich das morgen um meine gesundheit
natürlich vollkommen egal
nein verdammte scheiße hier du bist auch
drauf
so so so so so das genau richtig fixiert
minute dafür gebraucht dass gerade hier
so cool alles umzustellen so als nehme
ich mir hier irgendwie mit not und müden
mach ich mir jetzt so eine blöde tür
eigentlich wäre die aus drei farben
irgendwie so und jetzt habe ich endlich
sein zweiter gang
das sieht schon deutlich imposanter
ausfindig obwohl das hier irgendwie noch
so alles machen kann alles voll
eigentlich wäre noch cooler wenn ihr
auch noch so welche darauf werden wir
das coole wartet das hier das ist das
stört mich ein bisschen
ach da ist so hast du bist und dann
natürlich darauf so das ist schön
das ist doch mal ein schöner eingang ein
imposanter ringern dann gehen wir hin
nein wir gehen nicht nebenher wir gehen
hier durch jeder der irgendwie so war
mein grundstück reingeht dem mekka die
bitte in den kommentaren von kraft darf
man der mitte die tür benutzen muss dann
auch in einem rohbau benutzt man die tür
und geht nicht irgendwie über die zäune
darüber dass auf jeden fall wichtig da
müssen die leute hier darauf achten wenn
die hielt sich das mal angucken hier
noch alles
nach der stadt noch dahin jetzt weiß ich
noch nicht so richtig dass da drin so
bauen soll
und vor allem aus so wie ich die wände
irgendwie darstellen möchte wir haben
die dass die anderen ihr das ding
gemacht hat das allgemein als ein
bisschen offen gehalten oder den wir das
noch zu baut hier oben glaube ich und
das enthaltene fenster den direkten
blick auf das relativ geil zombie ist
glaube ich einfach so in irgendein haus
eingezogen sind 18 minuten ich glaub ich
jedoch nur folge auf weil ich grad
relativ gut drin wenn zombie hat einfach
ja zum kind einfach so einen kakao
stehlik september er hat da gar keine
fenster oder ähnliches im ostend wollte
auch noch machen heißt es am ostrand
komme ich bin jetzt richtig wenig auf
die kommentare eingegangen
aber egal so ein paar sachen armor
stellen ja was ist das hier am ostende
unterschied
ich find den cooler wohl eher 42
verschiedene ja ich finde den cooler der
hat nur den ja das mache ich auch das
cooler und sondern schwerter stand mach
ich dann auch noch mal du bist jetzt ist
meine goldene feder kaputt und jetzt
kriege ich fall schaden nicht okay aber
ich glaube wenn ich so jetzt von hier
darunter springe wieso kriegt kein
falsch an
die irgendwas oder nicht so passend dazu
dass es nacht wird werde ich das denke
ich hier erst mal so bauen auf jeden
fall in der jeder ecke kommt sowas so
dass eine zu geringe so fragt mich nicht
was ich dort baue ihr werdet mich in
frage luca wird dürfte da nicht das
einmal den kommentaren seele der
personen künftig auf den bund spart ja
so auf jeden fall muss ja ua möchten
dass jetzt wieder ein jazz transport
teil
aber ich würde sagen das machen wir doch
noch diese folge das schaffen noch eben
schnell davon brauche ich wieder 1000
am 4 nach 50 folgen
ok nach vier kenne das schreibt man die
kamera nach bin so blöd du kommst auch
noch mit verbindet ihr ich halt so dann
kommen noch so feiler purple hin da da
auf jeden fall
und ich würde sagen den rest machen wir
dann auf jeden fall erstmal der nächsten
folge so sieht bisher mein haus aus ob
das was wir werden mit ansehen musste
gucken nahm ich sagen jetzt erst mal
fünfter welcher sich immer wieder
beschwert
die regel ja sehr sehr ernst was
natürlich auch gut nur wegen zehn
sekunden sollte man jetzt nicht so den
elefanten und nagel
ihr wisst was ich meine wenn euch
gefallen natürlich mich auf jeden fall
über eine bewertung freuen wenn ihr
solche folgen wirkt gibt man einfach ein
daumen hoch wenn ich mir so kommentare
beantworten videos machen soll und dann
wird die frage wen wir uns
marken wieder oder man erhält jeder ein
video guckt euch unbedingt die animation
und diesmal